nothing is more adorable than a baby
Courtney don't argue
it's science unfortunately few things
are as messy as a baby Corgi good thing
Dyson just came out with a new Robo
vacuum it's called the 360 eye that r2d2
looking thing on top is a 360 degree
camera it maps your house to plan its
route hence the name 360 I Dyson claims
it has twice the suction power of other
vacuum robots it also cleans closer to
walls the Robo vacuum is pretty good at
loosening Corgi related grit from
carpets with its fiber brushes it also
has tank treads that means it's good at
tackling transitions between carpets and
hard surfaces
so let's put it to the test and we'll
begin with coffee grounds
good work for the box let's try glitter
because let's face it it gets everywhere
hmm not bad how about something bigger
like skittles the little robot friend
didn't like that very much so it's still
only half as powerful as a normal vacuum
and there's no second robot to empty the
bin so you'll need to do that yourself
as an added bonus you can set its
schedule with an app so if you've got a
thousand bucks sitting around the 360 I
is a solid Robo me